歡迎收看小森林
叫東京吃什麼Vlog
下飛機放下行李飛站就是有面
我朋友說
色谷這家他們感覺是最好吃的
我們當天晚上是九點多多道的
這是門口的排隊情況
大家感受一下它的呼吸
我們晚上跟他排了一枚多小時
終於是吃上它有一點類似日本的熱感面
我點的辣的
然後蘿蔔又加了一個湯心膽
按在一起吃
本公內人覺得很過位
其實我是林陳梁念中
配得給你我的咳細膽量流出來了
它的面真的非常驚到
在家上一杯冰可烙
是忘了
就有面是我每次來的必吃吧
吃完就去附近的店裡店逛了一下
這個據說是能提升睡眠的女兒
我一口乾了
然後給大家回報一下
某用沒有
我當我還是睡眠了
就睡那種
魯酸菌的味道
烏烏烏的
第一次搞這麼酷
我們去打卡了一架網紅布上去
是一架面包店
拋幸運就要六排隊
就是要點四的
所以我們三個人點了十二個面包
這裡的看上面包
大概真的很好吃
他們家會有外的眼費的
在配一些湯和沙拉這類的店
其實我覺得湯沙拉什麼都還好
但他們家這個送的
這個小杯的肉會奶茶
好好喝
他們每個人就送這麼一小杯
不想要單點一個大杯的
覺得沒有啊
別人不行
轉成轉成
吃完就來擺關山消失了
逛了一下啥都沒買找
下午就來這邊
一架排隊往吃一個下午餐
不用排隊真的
我訂了一個熱果茶和酸餅
但是我感覺是家一般
還沒有深圳的不利死好吃
但他們家環境很好很漂亮
就是很出偏的那種
晚上約了一家受洗燒
還是開在一家非常小的小銷子裡面的
他家的肉是我吃過的受洗燒
做一大的
就一片
頂人家好幾片
翻一場非常嫩
入口疑化
我們好像是訂的泡餐
一個人會有兩片
如果不夠的話
可以再額外的店
但是對我來說
兩片盒牛在家一些蔬菜
你現在之類的
就已經吃到福強走了
最後給我上的這一片肉
我只吃了一半
因為朋友吃多了還是有點日子
分享一下子上的海景
今天我準備換一家酒店
這次做的酒店
一出來就可以看到東京卡
中午就在酒店附近隨便找了一家
那一店
我店的這個又此風味的
這裡沒有一個選項是焦源球
很好奇是什麼東西
但的時候發現自己長的動
公布的等等
像古董一樣的東西
就是焦源球
直接把它倒進去
其實我覺得日本拉麵都有練習
可能不行
就不夠入味吧
晚上吃的一家歐麥咖啡
他們家的血頭是好像餐具
都用的是愛馬士的
其實我訂之前我覺得這種網紅
電話會不會不好吃
畢竟我是來吃美食的
我又不是來吃愛馬士的
但是我多率吧
真的
之後幾好吃
這個是我做出來的東西非常特別
而且它的原理特別的油目
我就一直一直在用它
幾真的那一點中文共說話
然後它知道我愛吃海膽
給我那麼一個超級的
具有霸海膽的受呼
一口下去
最後還好吃完了
是吧
我們剛才我就去散布了兩個小時
味的就是吃這家網紅
又子拉麵店
不店了兩種口味的
這個是拉味的
還有一個是他們的招牌
這個騰舞幼稚的
我個人覺得是拉的
會更好吃一些
第三天歐湖吐燉了
昨天買了一點高帽子
馬上帶上一頓拍
給大家分享一下歐湖的超越幼稚
懶掉時刻
今晚吃的是我們每次來的
壁吃店漫与飯
這家是我2019年隨便吃的家
沒想到
以戰風省直接變成了
我現在心中漫与飯
第一就是這家讓我以為日本的
每一家漫与飯都沒有那麼好吃
那我後面就吃了幾家別的
我發現好像都沒有這家好吃
他們家都是會考的
外面是那種交交的
然後你加一點點的
子書絲的充花
和他們家米飯辦在一起
一口下去
一個字
絕
就地牌妹妹本來說他不樂不吃
我說你真的要試試
這家來的來了
結果他光盤的比我還好快
吃完就在這家商場
你逛了一下
買了這家是你
看起來好可愛
面料要好舒服
結果回來之後
我在想說直播刷到只要
100多還是200多一件
算了
人家送了一個超可愛的水金球
這個情緒價值還是給到了
現在做地鐵去吃一家網工
並且因為我運車實在是
太難收了
這個地鐵站
我往我走下去好恐怖
他一個人都沒有
如果不是地牌妹妹
他的朋友可以跟我
我一定不敢走下去了
這個網工
並期令來了
我店的雙瓶
這個是交討的
留一點太甜了
但是並且你就是吃甜甜了吧
走到這個店真的地方了
還要馬來呀
全是人超極多的人
我用食拍了幾張照片
讓他們都懂了
實在是人太多了
點兩個大好
去這場之前又帶朋友
就吃了一個辣辣的又子辣面
嗯
都很滿意
然後就去機場回家囉